in the last video we tried to figure out
the slope of a point or the slope of a
curve at a certain point and the way we
did it we said okay well let's find the
slope between that point and then
another point that's not too far away
from that point and we got the slope of
the secant line it looks all fancy but
this is just the Y value of the point
that's not too far away and this is just
the Y value of your point of the point
in question so this is just your change
in Y and then you divide that by your
change in X so in the example we did H
was the difference between our two
x-values this distance was H and that
gave us the point that the slope of that
line we said hey what if we take the
limit as this as this point right here
gets closer and closer at this point if
this point essentially almost becomes
this point then our slope is going to be
the slope of our tangent line and we
define that as the derivative of our
function we said that's equal to f prime
of X so let's see if we can apply this
in this video to to maybe make things a
little bit more concrete in your head so
let me do one first I'll do a particular
case where I want to find the slope at
exactly some point so let's say let me
draw my axes again let's draw some axes
right there and let's say I have the
curve let's say I have the curve this is
the curve Y is equal to x squared so
this is my y-axis this is my x-axis and
I want to know the slope at the point X
is equal to 3 and when I say the slope
you can imagine a tangent line here do
it in a light yellow you can imagine a
tangent line that goes just like that
and it would just just barely graze the
curve at that point but what is the
slope of that tangent line what is the
slope of that tangent line which is the
same as the slope of the curve right at
that point so to do it I'm going to
actually do this exact technique that we
did before and then we'll generalize it
so you don't have to do it every time
for a particular number so let's take
some other point here let's take some
other point up out here let's call this
3 plus Delta X
I'll changing the notation because in
some books you'll see an H some books
you'll see a Delta X doesn't hurt to be
exposed to both of them so this is 3
plus Delta X so first of all what is
this point right here what is this point
right here this is a curve Y is equal to
x squared so f of X f of X is 3 squared
this is the point 9 this is the point 3
comma 9 right here let me draw that out
well I'll draw it out in a second and
what is this point right here so if we
were to go all the way up here what is
that point well here our X is now our X
is 3 plus Delta X it's the same thing as
this one right here is X not plus h I
could have called this 3 plus H just as
easily so it's 3 plus Delta X up there
so what's the Y value going to be
well whatever x value is it's on the
curve it's going to be that squared so
it's going to be this is going to be the
point 3 plus Delta X 3 plus Delta x
squared so let's figure out the slope of
this secant line let's figure out the
slope of the secant line let me zoom in
a little bit because that might help so
if i zoom in on just this part of the
curve it might look like that and then I
have one point here and then I have the
other point is up here you see if I can
draw that
that's the secant line secant secant
line just like that this was the point
over here this at this point is the
point 3 comma 9 and then this point up
here is the point 3 plus Delta X so it's
just some larger number than 3 and then
it's going to be that number squared so
it's going to be 3 plus Delta x squared
what is that that's going to be 9 I'm
just boiling this out or you do the
distributive property twice if you have
a plus B squared is a squared plus 2 a B
plus B squared so it's going to be 9
plus 2 times the product of these things
so plus 6 Delta X and then plus Delta x
squared plus Delta X plus Delta x
squared that's the coordinate of the
second line this looks complicated but I
just took this x-value and I squared it
because it's on the line y
is equal to x squared so the slope of
this line the slope of the secant line
is going to be the change in Y divided
by the change in X so the change in Y
the change in Y is just going to be this
guy's y-value which is 9 plus 6 Delta X
plus Delta x squared that's this guy's Y
value minus this guys Y value I'll do it
in green so minus 9 minus 9 that's your
change in Y and you want to divide that
by your change in X by your change in X
well what is your change in X this is
actually going to be pretty convenient
this larger x value we started with this
point on the top so we have to start
with this point on the bottom so it's
going to be 3 plus Delta X 3 plus Delta
X and then what's this x-value
well it's minus 3 minus 3 that's his
x-value so what does this simplify to
the numerator this 9 and that 9 cancel
out we get a 9 minus 9 and in the
denominator what happens this 3 and
minus 3 cancel out so the change in X
actually end up becoming this Delta X
which makes sense because that's this
Delta X is essentially how much more
this guy is than that guy so that should
be the change in X Delta X so the slope
of my secant line so my slope has
simplified to 6 times my change in X
plus my change in x squared all of that
over my change in X all of that over my
change in X and now we can simplify this
even more let's divide the numerator and
the denominator by our change in X and I
will switch colors just to ease the
monotony so of my slope of my tangent of
my secant line the one that goes through
both of these is going to be equal if
you divide the numerator denominators
becomes six right I'm just dividing
numerator denominator by Delta X plus 6
plus Delta X so that is the slope of the
secant line so slope slope is equal to
six plus Delta X that's this one right
here that's this reddish line that I've
drawn right there so if this number
right here if the Delta X was one
this was the point if these were the
points three and four then my slope
would be six plus one because I'm
picking a point four where the Delta X
here would have to be one so the slope
would be seven because so we have a
general formula for no matter what my
Delta X is I can find the slope between
three and three plus Delta X between
those two points now we wanted to find
the point the slope at exactly that
point right there so let's see what
happens when we take when Delta X gets
smaller and smaller this is what Delta X
is right now it's this distance but if
Delta X got a little bit smaller then it
would start the secant line would look
like that we've got even smaller the
secant line would look like that it gets
even smaller then we're getting pretty
close to the slope of the tangent line
the tangent line is this thing right
here that I want to find the slope of so
let's find the limit as our Delta X
approaches zero so the limit as Delta X
approaches zero of our slope of the
secant line of six plus Delta X is equal
to what this is pretty straightforward
you can just set this equal to zero and
it is equal to six so the slope of our
tangent line the slope of our tangent
line at the point X is equal to three
right there is equal to six and another
way we could write this if we wrote that
f of X is equal to x squared we now know
that the derivative or the slope of the
tangent line of this function at the
point three I just only evaluated it at
the point three right there that that is
equal to six
I haven't yet come up with a general
formula for the slope of this line at
any point and I'm going to do that in
the next video